My name is Johnny Harris and I make
videos here at Vox.
I spent my entire
last year traveling around to different
places making documentaries on the topic
of Borders.
I'm excited to announce that Borders is
back. I'm hitting the road again to go tell
the story of some of the most
interesting places in the world.
We're stuck again.
The first location for this
next round of Borders is going to be:
Hong Kong.
I'm doing things a little bit
differently this time. Instead of going
to these places to focus on one major
topic and to make like a 15 minute
documentary about that topic,
I'm actually gonna be making a lot more
videos from these places.
I'm gonna stay there a little bit longer and make more
videos that are more narrow and a little
bit shorter.
Wait, so no more sweet
documentaries with all the fancy
graphics?
No, no no no no. That's not what I'm saying.
These are still gonna be beautiful, really well
produced pieces, they're just gonna be a
little bit more narrow in their scope
and they're gonna be shorter, but there's
gonna be a bunch more of them.
Okay, cool.
As always I'm looking for your help in
finding and reporting these stories.
If you live in Hong Kong or Macau or have
traveled there or read something
interesting about it, I want to hear
about it.
It doesn't necessarily have to
be about conflict or the political
situation, it can be about an interesting
community or an interesting restaurant
or figure or person.
I just want to know
what's worth explaining about this
peculiar part of the world.
If you do have some ideas, I want to hear about it.
You can go to Facebook or Instagram and
DM me.
Now if you do live in Hong Kong
Macau and you want to meet up with me
when I travel there next month or you
want to contribute to Borders in some
other way,
go to:
vox.com/borders-local
where you can fill out a form
telling me a little bit more about
yourself and how you'd be willing to
contribute to Borders.
This could be
anything from me asking you to film
something on your cell phone that you
see every day or filming a part of your
life that would be really interesting
for these stories.
So the last thing I'll say is that we
just created this Facebook Watch page,
which is a Facebook page basically
optimized for viewing videos.
That's where I'm going to be posting all the
Border's content first, so if you want to
kind of subscribe or follow Borders
content only, that's the place to go.
It's gonna be a lot cleaner than following my
personal pages which are usually like,
photos of my family.
If you want just the
Border's content go follow this page and
you'll get a notification every time
there's some new update or new video
that's published.
Okay, housekeeping items
out of the way.
Borders Hongkong is officially in motion.
I'm excited to hear what stories you come up with.
And yes I plan to wear this orange coat
until the day it comes unstitched.